يقول astrazeneca إن 79 بالمائة فعالة
ضد جميع الأمراض
100 فعالة ضد الحالات الشديدة والاستشفاء
ماذا يعني هذا وماذا قد
يكون التأثير هنا في الولايات المتحدة ،
أعتقد أن هذه أخبار جيدة جدًا أن
يكون لديك لقاح آخر
يمكن أن يُصرح به ثم
يُضاف إلى
أعتقد في الواقع أن أفضل الأخبار
حول أسترازينيكا هي أنهم
لم يجدوا أي أحداث سلبية أو لم يعثروا على أحداث سلبية كبيرة
بما في ذلك
الجلطات الدموية
التي أثار البعض مخاوف بشأنها في
أوروبا ، لذا أعتقد أن هذا يجب أن يكون
مطمئنًا حقًا
بما في ذلك الناس في جميع أنحاء العالم
نظرًا لأن لقاح أسترازينيكا يُنظر
إليه على أنه لقاح عالمي ،
فإنه غير مكلف ، فمن السهل تخزينه
ونقله وأعتقد أنه يضيف مرة أخرى إلى إمداداتنا
المحتملة
هنا في الولايات المتحدة ، على
الرغم من أنه بحلول الوقت الذي
يتم فيه تقديم astrazeneca للحصول على
إذن وبعد ذلك  تمت الموافقة فعليًا
على الاستخدام هنا ،
فمن المحتمل أن نكون في هذه
الحالة ، وفي هذه الحالة يكون لدينا جميعًا في الواقع  لقاحات أخرى من
المحتمل أن تكون متوفرة
بشكل كافٍ لذلك لا أعتقد أن هذا
يؤثر علينا في الولايات المتحدة
بقدر ما يؤثر في جميع أنحاء العالم